this is ETC caviar and all of this would
cost fifty six hundred dollars the
amount from these 16 tens could come
from a single Etc sturgeon which has to
be raised for at least seven years
before its eggs are ready for harvesting
this fish is about 12 years old value
approximately three to four thousand
dollars
Farm These twenty thousand sturgeons
sustainably takes five hundred thousand
dollars a year in operating costs
from the feed to the ultrasound checks
to the very water that keeps them alive
each one of those drum filters you see
is about 30k we visited marshallberg
Farm's 10 million dollar facility in
Smyrna North Carolina to see how they
produce hundreds of kilograms of caviar
[Music]
one of the largest costs of this whole
operation is the water behind me are 12
grow out tanks each containing about 40
000 gallons of water with about 300 fish
a piece these pipes are the lifeline for
the fish they pump oxygenated water into
the tanks and pump back treated
Wastewater to this part of the facility
the water goes through this
recirculating aquaculture system or Ras
for short and in one hour the res system
can filter through a million gallons of
water
a potential oversight during a routine
inspection could lead to massive
repercussions we've had our share of
incidents here I've come in and and
found a tank full of floating fish
before so only after everything is
checked can staff move on to actually
feeding the fish
the feed is specially formulated so it
doesn't float or disintegrate and it's
distributed along the perimeter of the
tanks so all 300 sturgeon have a better
chance of being fed we can feed them two
pounds of feed and expect roughly one
pound of growth approximate cost of the
feed is about 75 cents a pound the rough
total for our facility per day is about
400 pounds of Feed in any given month we
expect 20 feed days so you can do the
math on roughly how much it takes to
operate just this facility alone that
math adds up to 72 thousand dollars a
year we have a significant economic
reason to go after and raise only
females females of course go for our
caviar operation and males go to more of
our me heat operation which is only
about five percent of our total revenue
the challenge is you got to still raise
the males up to that five-year Point
that's because up until five years the
fish can't be gender identified we have
to look at their gonadal structure in
order to determine that and that's only
large enough when the fish is of a
certain age once the females are
identified they're separated from the
males and they live out their remaining
days in these tanks until their eggs are
ready just give you a sense of scale
these fish I have some here in 2018
uh they're now five years of age the
older the fish the larger the yield and
every quarter the farmers carefully sort
through each of the 300 sturgeon by hand
to see if any are viable for caviar
production out of 300 fish in here we're
expecting to be able to harvest caviar
from 60 fish this season these fish here
we got them in 2011 so they're now going
on 12 years of age and these are prime
candidate fish for caviar this year they
keep their interference with the fish to
a minimum in order to reduce stress
because stressed out fish don't make
caviar you got a Whopper so you got
something in there
it is a little softer
we do a palpation of the fish on the
belly to make sure that there's
something in there for us to look at
maybe maybe maybe if they feel potential
for eggs in a fish's belly they'll
perform an ultrasound
okay so what we're seeing here on the
ultrasound what appears to be these
little white splotches which are
individual eggs we can get a profile
view of the entire diameter and roughly
project yields based on what we see here
a biopsy will help them test a sample of
the row I think we found a good caviar
fish take a peek this we think this one
looks all right
so you can see the eggs stay in the
channel of the biopsy tool we can assess
the firmness of the egg color texture
and make a prediction that this fish
will yield a road that we can make into
that really good pop
a quality caviar so this is not caviar
this is row at this point only after
salting the packing does it become
caviar eggs change in texture and size
during each cycle so if Farmers miss the
window to harvest they have to wait at
least a year to see if that fish has new
eggs with caviar potential if it's
really squishy it's gone past the time
when we should be harvesting it because
if we don't do this step we're going to
kill a fish that could potentially yield
us great caviar later on down the road
but if we don't get good caviar now it
has no market value so it's very
critical harvesting occurs when a fish
is at least seven to eight years old the
sturgeons are euthanized before their
row is extracted then we'll screen that
Rose sack then we will salt the row and
finally we'll place it on a screen where
we'll pick through it with a pair of
tweezers any form matter out of there or
little blood clots or imperfectly shaped
eggs we'll pick through that one by one
by one and this takes about an hour long
process before we pack it into a tin bag
vacuum seal it and then cold store that
tin so this is where we store all the
caviar it's organized by grade and this
tin size every Harvest is labeled with a
designated Lot number which traces back
to one fish and a small sample is set
aside for each Lot number during the
harvesting process with osetra you know
it's part of the grading system is color
Etc caviar has a tendency to have a
golden undertone and like the more
golden it is it can be considered a
higher grade marshallberg Farm primarily
produces three major grades of caviar
every day classic and Royal and
occasionally some rare grades like this
gold reserve the grading is based on
appearance texture and flavor and flavor
is just it's just almost instinct is it
really buttery Savory you know some just
tastes a lot richer than others Leanne
can grade as many as 60 lot numbers in a
day during the busy season and the
process can take up to four hours a day
I'm gonna use my hand because it has no
flavor and my brain will not associate
any flavors with it
it's got a Nutty buttery flavor got some
pop to it so I would call this a classic
grain marshallberg Farm started their
operation in 2011 with about five
thousand fingerlings now they have 20
000 sturgeon with the projected caviar
production of up to 1500 kilograms this
year that's more than double what they
produced last year
the U.S imported 17.8 million dollars
worth of caviar in 2018 with half of
those Imports coming from China but in
recent years interest in domestic caviar
has grown but we're getting to the point
now where our demand and sales outstrip
our operating costs and their operating
costs now include efforts to spawn their
crop on site growing their next
generation of sturgeon we have an
imperative to complete the loop here
ourselves but knowing that we have quite
a significant inventory so that affords
us the luxury of some time to get
spawning right in this tank we keep
brood stock fish in the hopes of
spawning them
we hope that they just do their job
naturally and we come out here one day
and get lucky and find a bunch of
fertilized eggs
and always have a dream
[Music]